I want to
who is the director of student services
at the University of Connecticut Law
School and an assistant clinical
professor here at the Child Study Center
and we've been working seeing cases
together over the last year or so which
has been very interesting they have done
some conferences together and as you're
going to hear our focus today is college
students on the autism spectrum which is
a very interesting new topic a new issue
at Yale at the moment we have several
undergraduates who have self-identified
as having autism which was great and
it's presented some issues around the
country but it's a delightful new
problem to have and so we're going to
hopefully put this up on the web as a
resource and let me just say as I
introduced Jane I also want to thank a
lot of people certainly Yale for
providing us with the infrastructure who
are doing this but also the fire fund
and the Taylor Family Foundation which
gives us some financial support to do
this lecture series that being said Jane
is going to start and then I'm going to
follow up and we'll have some time for
questions Jane Thank You Fred thank you
all for coming I do a few things and I
come to this College work both
personally and professionally I've been
in disability services in higher ed for
35 years working with students with all
kinds of disabilities and about 20 years
ago started seeing students who really
didn't fit what their diagnosis said and
started looking further it was about 15
years ago that Fred and I started having
some conversations about could this
really be at the time it was Asperger's
or high-functioning autism that we were
seeing with all these college students
who were usually diagnosed with OCD or a
learning disability what we want to talk
to you today is more how to prepare
students for college and how how do we
know when they're getting ready for
college and what kinds of things we need
when I say I come at this very
personally and professionally we're a
fragile X family we have three children
and my youngest is a 24 year old who is
severely autistic he's not going to
college but because I live in that world
of parents of kids with autism I see a
very different kind of experience for
parents who are going through special
education systems versus my professional
experience of working with college
students with this
so with that we really want to talk
about what life is like after high
school because many families are really
thinking but just if he or she can get a
degree if this if this young person can
get a college degree then everything
will be ok and that's really not the way
we want to think we really need to think
towards we need people to be independent
successful adults that's the key rather
than just getting that degree
can I ask I know a lot of your students
do we have any parents here today
parents of folks on the spectrum okay so
at graduation from high school
everything changes and we're going to
talk about this in about the 20 minutes
I have so we're going to talk very
briefly the laws change
who's in charge changes drastically the
expectations of the individual really
change it goes from a real valley to a
very high peak the temptations for the
student changed drastically as do the
consequences and what many families are
not prepared for is the accommodations
in college change drastically once
you're out of high school there is no
special education so who's the driver in
all this in middle in high school the
parents and guardians have to be driving
this whole charge the teachers and
counselors really drive that IEP and
make those deliverable accommodations
happen but once you get to college this
student is the driver but even if the
parents act as guardian or our legal
guardian they cannot call the shots at
college the student has to be the one in
charge of their education the way we
like to put it is in middle school in
high school the parents the Guardians
the teachers the guidance counselor's
the social workers and clinicians they
are advocate and CEO of that students
education but once the student gets to
college they are their own advocate and
CEO and what we're trying to impress is
that families need to give that student
time to learn
and to train to become advocate and CEO
of their own education in 2000 there
were only two college programs in this
country for students with autism many
disability service offices and colleges
really did not know about autism what it
was or how students with autism could
function on their campuses but today in
2016 there at least 25 and by fall there
will be about thirty to thirty two
programs specifically for college
students with autism and there's even
more with what we call enhanced services
there's not a full-blown program but
colleges do some specific things for
students with autism and all of those
are on our website College autism
spectrum comm the highest numbers right
now this year for the 1516 academic year
is the University of Texas at Dallas
which works with about a thousand
students with disabilities in general
three hundred and seventy five of whom
have autism documented and disclosed to
disability services that 375 is the
highest number in the country so what do
students need to be ready for college
this comes from a grant called
technology for transition from SUNY
Buffalo this was developed in 1979 if
you notice it looks like it was
developed specifically for students with
autism but this was in general what all
students needed way back thirty-five
thirty-six years ago the major skills
needed by entering college students
study habits being prepared for class
being organized an understanding
classroom etiquette which many faculty
complain that neurotypical students have
problems with today social skills being
able to interact appropriately being
able to interact in social situations
dealing with feedback on papers and
exams that peer pressure that everybody
has to deal with and independent living
skills students need to be able to
structure their environment from that
very structured high school setting
where everything is very locked in all
day you move to a college setting we're
only 12 to 15 hours
weak are structured for the student and
we know that students with autism like
structure and don't do very well with
unstructured time which is the downfall
for a lot of folks with autism at
college using leisure time can do I know
when to get off the video games and
start studying do I know when to turn
off the TV and start studying that's
difficult for any typical college age
student eighteen to twenty-two for the
student with autism even more difficult
articulating medical needs how many of
our students go to a doctor make their
own appointments or go independently to
a doctor before going to college that's
often very challenging for families to
deal with and then your basic adapted
living skills transportation cooking
laundry all those things that you have
to be able to deal with once you get to
a college campus so what's really
important for college success what I
hear from families regularly five to ten
times a week but dr. Brown you don't
understand how bright this person is and
I understand that you can be incredibly
bright and still struggle with things at
college the important things for college
success are number one resilience do you
have that ability to bounce back when
things are tough that's social
communication and interaction can you
function in a classroom in a residence
hall in a group executive function that
future planning
can I put things together to get those
assignments done to juggle multiple
assignments at once bless you
self-regulation if things are bad and
I'm upset can I get myself back on track
and then academic ability which
certainly is in the mix but it's not the
number one most important thing needed
in order to be successful in college
we've all seen people that we really
didn't think would be successful in
college be able to get through college
because of the other qualities that they
had even though they might struggle
academically where some of our students
with brilliant academic Minds struggle
even more
those other students so how do we build
this resilience that's so important one
of the hardest things to do for students
with any disability but especially those
on the spectrum is not accommodating
every need we so badly want to help we
soar badly want to make this person
successful that we often do just what we
should we eliminate all the risk we make
sure that person can't fail we do lots
behind the scenes to make sure that that
self-esteem stays intact but in what
we're doing then is taking away that's
person's ability to learn those
problem-solving skills that are so
important and many of our students are
graduating from high school not having
learned how to solve their own problems
we need to avoid asking why questions
why did you do that why did you let that
happen and instead ask how how are you
now going to make this work you didn't
do the math assignments for the last two
weeks how are you gonna make this work
and pass that class letting the student
figure out how to make things work
rather than pushing the why why would
you do that or why would you do that to
me which a lot of us as parents get
involved in sometimes thinking it's more
an interpersonal thing we have to let
our kids make mistakes and it's hard to
do it's even harder for a student with
autism we have to let them make mistakes
and figure out what happens after the
mistake because we all know that
mistakes are going to happen and that if
we try and make all that to smooth and
the road to smooth for students with
autism that then becoming independent
successful adults is a much harder
journey that they need time while they
still have support of family around to
be able to make those mistakes help the
students manage their emotions don't
manage them for them help teach the
student to manage those emotions and
help know what to do during a meltdown
or when things get sensibly overwhelming
and then most important is to model that
resiliency I meet with lots of families
to talk about college off
and college counseling and often the
families are so stressed and overwhelmed
by this process that I can't imagine how
the student can get through the process
because if they're looking at the parent
for guidance and that parent is falling
apart how is the student going to get
through this process in this long
transition so we do know by 2020 we're
going to have a half million new adults
who will have turned 21 with autism this
is from the Autism Society of America a
couple of years ago but we know from the
numbers being identified and the
prevalence through the CDC right now
that by 2020 we will have a new half
million adults looking for services so
what do we know that's changed and what
do we have to do to prepare for this
large group we know that the students
are coming to college less prepared in
some areas again academically they may
be very well prepared but they may be
much less prepared in some of those
other social and adaptive skills we know
the parents are much more involved much
more involved than they were a decade
ago and much more involved than even a
few years ago but we also know that
colleges are much more prepared where it
used to be no one's heard of autism at a
college campus and no one imagined a
student with autism could be a college
student
now every college has many students with
autism every College in the country
and some colleges are doing more than
others one of the important things to
realize and that we certainly want
people that are helping to transit
transition folks from high school to
college to understand is how different
the laws are I say again because it
bears repeating after high school there
is no special education there is no
special education in college for
students the laws change drastically
under I DEA the individuals with
Disabilities Education Act it's a
federal law of educational entitlement
the parent and the school and are
responsible and ensures success in that
you can't fail out of special education
if you are a mandated
special ed student and you have an IEP
they can't come to a parent and say
sorry
your student has failed out they can't
come to school anymore that's not
allowed
it's educational entitlement and it's
based on evaluation and remediation and
the school will give a diagnostic label
one of the 13 federal categories once
you have gotten either that high school
diploma or certificate of completion you
now move over to the a da which is now
known as the a D Triple A the Americans
with Disabilities Act Amendments Act
this is not federal law this is civil
rights legislation of equal access
totally different and most people have
no idea when their student graduates
from high school and goes to college
that these are totally different laws my
role as a disability service provider is
not to ensure success we give permission
to succeed and permission to fail like
every other college student by leveling
the playing field so it's my job as a
disability service provider to read
documentation evaluate the student in a
way that will level them to the other
students in class and give them an equal
advantage not the best possible
accommodations so that they can succeed
in the best way possible because we'd
love to do that for every student but
that would mean telling the organic
chemistry professor that every student
needs double the time that they're going
to give them for an exam and the
professors say no this is for what I'm
examining and the professor in college
has that academic right it's base the
student is now responsible rather than
the parent and the school so when the
parents say no no no but I'll have to
talk to the faculty the student has to
talk to the faculty it's a totally
different model and it we provide
reasonable accommodations and that
reasonable is very important based on
functional impairment and impairment in
a major life activity totally different
laws that most families that have
special education student in high school
aren't being informed about and all of
this kind of comes as a shock when that
student moves on to to college students
in the world of college services must be
otherwise qualified they have to be
admitted to the college able to attend
class like other students and they have
to meet all the academic and behavioral
standards nothing gets changed because a
student has a disability and that last
piece is very important the student has
to be able to advocate for themselves
with minimal assistance so what do we do
now we need to prep our students to
understand their assessment understand
their strengths and weaknesses because
the mom and dad and psychologists are
not going to be in meetings with the
student and their faculty or their
disability service providers the
students really need to understand their
learn how they learn and how they learn
best and they need a chance to practice
disclosing to teachers and and staff in
the high schools before they get to
college students need to be able to do
the following things number one wake
themselves up in the morning you
wouldn't believe how many families are
still waking up their high school
students and they get to college and
can't understand why the students can't
get to class students need to be able to
wake themselves up before they leave
high school they should be running those
IEP meetings because they need to know
what their accommodations are about they
need to practice scheduling their own
appointments mom and dad aren't going to
email the professor to make an
appointment for you the student needs to
practice things like that refilling
their own meds making sure they have a
good time management system and we find
students really aren't having enough
opportunities for volunteer jobs before
they leave high school and it's a
crucial crucial step and those
independent living skills are really
important I really like to reinforce
this to families we are not applying to
college the student is applying to
college and sometimes we lose sight of
that we know that from about five years
ago the Journal of Pediatrics did a
study and found that 66 percent of young
adults with autism
we're not working or continuing their
education after high school only one in
three folks on the spectrum graduating
from high school we're doing anything
outside the home and we need to change
that with the numbers coming up we need
to change that drastically and we need
more of us working with young adults on
the spectrum we have lots of folks
working with children on the spectrum we
need to increase the young and adults
and adult service providers and
clinicians so how do we improve we need
to start earlier we need to start this
transition before students step onto the
college campus or before they graduate
from high school
we need realistic supported transition
not just a plan that's in an IEP and
then we set the student off and we need
real collaboration between the high
schools the clinicians the family and
the college service providers all
together to make a successful transition
for the students I think we're gonna
take questions after so I'll finish
there and ask Fred to come up thank you
I will be planted in front of the
microphone and here's my outside voice
and so I'm gonna follow up and I hope
without much in the way so I think that
maybe a little bit of duplication but
hopefully not too much with Jane and as
you heard she and I've been seeing folks
which has been very interesting students
and their families and I would agree
very much with Jane we are not applying
to college the student is applying to
college let me say to set the stage for
this they're given the number of people
we're going to see in the explosion
there's a range of options for people
after school one is vocational programs
we now actually have a number as you
heard from James supported transitional
programs we also have a network around
the country a very good community
colleges often people could live at home
go to school during the daytime Gateway
here in New Haven for example meetings
of that then we have traditional
four-year colleges and we have something
like five thousand I think around the
country these vary tremendously and
again we'll talk a little bit about that
and for some people are going on to
graduate and professional school if we
have time at the end I'll give you some
examples of the kinds of things we're
seeing the good news Kyle just came out
of monasteries why is that good news
monasteries are very structured things
happen on time you go to prayer at a
certain time and it's sort of a legacy
of our monastic roots that we use a lot
of routines things are available if you
show up at the lunch place there would
be food if you show up at the library
there are books there's stuff and to
some extent and this varies tremendously
from school to school you can minimize
social interaction but it's impossible
to totally absolutely get rid of it so
it's an important issue at the same time
there are rules as is true of
monasteries as well and if you violate
those rules you're out and as you heard
from Jay if you're a special Institute
with an IEP you're not out you're gonna
be gonna be there through high school
college you make an inappropriate
comment to a lady often that's going to
get you kicked out very quickly
education matters any kind of
post-secondary education helps people
get a job that's the good news and also
students who have disabilities but who
get a bachelor's degree on average for
all students with disabilities it may be
slightly different for people in the
autism spectrum they get jobs at about
the same rate as their neurotypical
peers but takes a lot to get people
through college sometimes there are many
accommodations that are available as
you're heard this is different than high
school and the student has to ask for
those these him or herself
there's untimed test tutors note takers
there's a lot of computer supports these
days text-to-speech speech to text you
can dictate to your computer you can use
PowerPoint to outline papers social
issues issues with peers the need for
long term life coaching supports if we
have a chance I'll tell you an example
at the end of that kind of thing and we
didn't need mental health supports
especially for the student who's
actively getting mental health supports
in high school well that's counseling
from the school psychologist whether
it's medications for anxiety
depression people need to keep that in
mind where they're going to look at
schools what are this resources both at
the college and in the community and
also as you heard the student has to be
very involved in self-advocacy I cannot
tell you the number of times parents say
but the college won't talk to me
that's because you're not part of the
equation you are paying the bills but
the student has the right to privacy and
only if the student gives up that right
can parents be involved obviously also
in a very rare exception of horrible
emergency situations the easiest thing
in my experience to deal with is helping
people understand that untimed tests are
helpful to our population often
processing speed is slow you can also
often demonstrate that on psychological
testing you can say look look at this
this requires an accommodation problem
areas and my experience essay questions
what are you gonna do with this respond
to this poem of Shakespeare's you know
if people get very literal and they have
trouble understanding Shakespeare is not
talking about what it looks like he's
talking about he's talking about
something else and usually it's love and
sex which is another problem English
courses in papers following up on
Shakespeare often hard for people to get
group works and and labs the student can
know so much he can overwhelm his
neurotypical lab partner or conversely
be totally left out a classroom behavior
not having your hand up all the time
I've had people who felt badly they were
made fun of by the professor in their
course because they were always asking
questions judicial affairs and again
especially around sexual issues also
around aggression things people might
think of it because they think that they
say it talking about Osama bin Laden
talking about being worried about bombs
that's the kind of thing that will get
you picked up and into trouble very
quickly the kinds of academic supported
programs some are very minimal this is
the life it's a probably the most common
model around the country people at the
college level are giving the a minimal
amount of service for what they can
given what they can do moderate whoops
sorry moderate a little more extensive
with some coordination of services and
we have more of these programs around
the country and we have the small
handful of very intensive sometimes
college prep sometimes beginning
programs often there will be a mix of
ekiden
classes and some special classes life
skills classes how do you take the bus
how do you have a bank account how do
you make a doctor's appointment college
residents residential life obviously if
you could live in a residence you will
have a different experience than living
at home commuter issues raised some
problems I'll talk about those in a
second residential issues how do you
have friends how do you socialize how to
use your free time you can't play all
you know minecraft or whatever is you
know 24/7 right you have to study some
of the time coping with roommates this
can be really hard suitemates is a
little simpler but even that has its own
challenges laundry and personal hygiene
I worked with a student here for a
couple of years and at the beginning his
freshman year he was sending every other
week a big box home to his mom by UPS of
his dirty clothes because he could not
tolerate the laundry room and even at
2:00 a.m. in the morning people are in
the laundry room they're hanging out
there creaking they're smoking pots
doing stuff and it's really hard to cope
with sleep patterns often our kids have
a long history of sleep patterns
problems and they're sleeping in the
daytime they're gone and that's not
going to be compatible with college life
relationships and understanding the
rules this is really one of the hardest
things the good news is we do have
people who are doing better and better I
know the number of people now who are
married and have families which is
fantastic but it's a hard road to get
there supporting the students as you
heard we want the student to be involved
in this you can provide therapy and
counseling you can teach social skills
you can teach organizational and study
skills and again you want to give people
tools to do this on their own we can
provide targeted assistance for certain
problems reading comprehension and so
forth and there's a lot of Technology
there's more and more that's coming out
all the time and the reference list at
the end will have a list of some of the
technology resources that people can use
you can alter the learning about
environment by using all kinds of aids
proofreading programs no takers you can
allow flexibility in terms of testing
procedures I had one student who fell
apart with untuk with it when a pop quiz
came up he was just a basket case he
couldn't take the anxiety
we worked it out with the professor he
was the only student that got a warning
the day before the night before of a pop
quiz at midnight and he couldn't do any
more study but he knew was coming up so
it wasn't his anxiety provoking and this
was worked out with the professor and it
worked fine and providing tutor tutoring
and special mentoring mentors can be
very helpful in many ways not just in
the academic sense as you heard people
have to be self advocating they have to
be motivated they already have to have
good study habits they have to have
classroom etiquette and they have to
have a whole range of skills around
executive functioning planning time
management not getting stuck on one
thing the students got to do this
English essay just can't get off of it
and keeps working and working and
working for that student he needs to
work out he has an hour there's a time
when it's done he's done he moves on to
the next thing no matter what he's done
having alternative strategies and
approaches thinking about other ways to
kind of work around the problem often
when our students hit a roadblock
they're right there with the roadblock
and they don't see well you you go left
or right
social interpersonal things like
conversation Huber one of the problems
we have often as people don't understand
idiosyncratic language said the students
idiosyncratic language when they talk
about something in a very unusual way
nobody has a clue conversely our
students will have trouble with things
like figurative language idioms sarcasm
irony it'll be lost on them sometimes
they will be laughed at whether or not
meaning to make a joke I give the
example of someone who works for us too
in copying the first time I had an
interaction with him I left him think to
copy with a yellow stickies saying could
you make three copies Joe the next day I
come back there's no copies please
written yes on the paper he could make
three copies he's responded to little
question but that's the kind of thing
that students will laugh at and the
student with autism won't understanding
it as you heard emotion management
independence regulating your own self
and time and space with your feelings
understanding your feelings things like
transport how do you get around in the
bus system time management laundry
cafeteria shopping laundry and cafeteria
are actually
very difficult there very unstructured
there's a lot of social interaction the
good news and bad news for students
thinking about a program there are a lot
of programs out there and there are more
coming down the pike and that's great
they vary in many different ways the
student and a family need to do their
homework this involves going online
asking for materials and visiting
programs the strategies for finding a
good fit for the college start early use
online searches as for the materials
look at summer programs see if there's
something you could do and spend time in
the summer to get to know the campus to
get a sense of what it's like
especially after you're admitted and
there's the whole question of when you
want to disclose if ever many of our
students say nobody in college will
realize nobody will realize I have a
problem and they'll say it like that and
you realize okay they'll know it the
first second thing you open your mouth
visiting the programs having the student
engaged as Jane said this is the
students college experience it's not the
parents ask a lot of questions have the
students involved and get a sense of the
fit on campus and don't and it can't
predict I've had students who had great
success at extremely small liberal arts
schools in the middle of nowhere and
I've had students have great success at
big ten colleges many of which have
great disability support programs I've
also seen the reverse so keep in mind
you really need to think about
goodness-of-fit having a vision thing
that we want if you heard is we wanted
an adult who's self-sufficient
independent and happy with their life
and it's not just the academics that's
the single most common thing parents
don't get is it's not just how bright
you are it's how functional you are and
there are many different paths
independent and supports so again ask
what's the best program for this student
how independent can the student be can
he really handle a full-time college
experience does it need to be part-time
does he need to go to the junior college
for a couple years or even a year to get
a sense of taking classes taking one or
two classes how does it work the
residential living at home if it's
residential visiting the college is
critical to see what the options are
also seeing what the support options are
at the school and schools vary
tremendously in terms of the range of
things of
maybe somebody will ask Jane what her
experience is it's um the best colleges
in the country we'll see if it's the
same list is mine meeting the learning
disability Support Officer again you can
decide whether you want to do this in
advance or not and whether you want to
self-identify or not once you're in
college the student has to be the one as
you heard to advocate for themselves and
go ask for support and look at the
curriculum things like it's a language
required this is a very common thing
language is going to be very difficult
for many of our students it can be a big
deal to get an exception if the college
has a language requirement the visit
again do your homework meet the support
staff find out how responsive they are
do they have a track record they have
experience doing this remember college
is not a right the students responsible
for their behavior their assignments
their independence and students are
really very quickly expelled sadly for
bad behavior I've had this experience
several times now people who will come
up they want to have a relationship with
someone they will be very polite and
they will make a very explicit request
and typically the second time they do
that they're out and the students is
what I would different you know I would
never do anything to a girl without
asking and they're right but and the but
is they're asking and they don't know
all the steps in between again getting a
feeling of the campus to get out of the
car one of my favorite stories are
taking our kids and college tours so we
get to some little school in Maine and
that my daughter says I don't like this
college I'm not gonna that's right I
don't like the town well you haven't
seen a girl you really want the kid to
get out of the car and look at the
college look L so at how sophisticated
the learning disabilities office and
officer is some of these people have
very minimal training others have a lot
of training you look at somebody like
change she is an expert so UConn is
really covered at a very high level with
somebody with an advanced degree in
special ed other schools this that the
learning disabilities officer may have a
little bit of training in something but
not necessarily so relevant to this also
look at the mental health supports other
kinds of services that might be
available in the community you can be in
a very small school out in the middle of
the sticks there's a social worker comes
in every other week maybe a shrink comes
in once a month
if you have a student on medications
who's really needing active social
skills therapy you need to take that on
board and also talk to other parents
find out who's graduating from the
college often when you go online you'll
find you can type in you know the name
of the college graduates but then get
into it and discover coz you will find
people who have had other kinds of
disabilities pros and cons two-year
college the pros it's easier in some
ways with open enrollment or two-year
school you don't have to take a full
load if you want you can have a track
record of success you've got a lot of
experience and that could then take you
to a more typical four-year college cons
often these community colleges are less
academically challenging for the bright
students they feel badly they're feeling
like they already know more than the
teacher and at the same time they're
processing with their classmates no more
than them socially so this is a set up
for them feeling depressed and isolated
and lonely and I've seen that happen
sadly transitional programs often look
at support and employment and work
skills and as you heard we not just
college but thinking about getting
people out so they can work
independently things like time
management financial management grocery
shopping laundry home maintenance
getting involved in the community
community supports can be very critical
being involved in a church a synagogue a
mosque whatever it is being involved in
community activities that you can
participate in and people will know you
people will check up on you people
you'll have a little community are the
Communist problems in college students
are often unwilling to ask for help
the student has to ask for it we can
have a range of technology supports but
they're only helpful if they're
implemented you can have a computer it
just sits there doesn't do you much good
the mental health issues again I would
underscore be aware of what the school
offers and what's available in the
community there can be private services
as well this college may be more willing
to provide academic supports if there's
an advocate at school for the student
challenges for mental health the most
common problems depression anxiety and
isolation this has got to be about 50%
of the students in my experience have
some degree of this bullying can be a
problem
people probably know the u.s. stands
sort of in the middle of the bullying
tack around the world if you're on the
autism spectrum your risk of being
bullied is something like 40% at some
point your school career if you have an
additional problem like anxiety and
depression it goes up to about 70 75 %
and again have a sense of the campus and
how much tolerance or intolerance there
is of bullying stress management
psychotherapy approaches have been nice
modifications of caught in a behavior
therapy specifically for individuals
with autism spectrum disorders this can
be great you have to adopt a life
coaching model realizing after 10
sessions even though your goal is to
wrap the problem up in 10 sessions this
is a person who's going to have to come
back and get help periodically and to be
open and flexible about that I mentioned
the disclosure issues and
confidentiality are very complicated in
this country in Canada if you're going
to college they will know ahead of time
well this is a person who's had a
diagnosis of ADHD or autism and this
company no no not at all and once you're
in school the mental health
professionals and the college will keep
everything private and confidential and
helping the college staff be aware the
student has some special needs and
supports but it's interested in learning
if the student really wants to learn off
to the colleges or supportive so what's
the secret to intervention in this
population be explicit tell your physics
teacher you need extra time on tests
let's write that down so you don't
forget it let's put it in your organizer
I get very explicit and very proactive
again you can't solve the problem of
what he's got to say to the physics
teacher but he's got to know he's got to
go do it or he's gonna flunk out in
summary students need to work on
self-awareness advocacy they need to
self identify to get special services
often they can use the college
experience as other people do to get on
to independence in a job you can become
part of a network of other students if
you're somebody who goes to Yale for
example your network is is a very social
school they're networked into all kinds
of people you know around the world
parents can help with the college search
but it's not their College search and
they have to own up to that they have to
learn when to be involved and when to
pull back and they do have to be
available to the students not to say
that not still parents they very much
are
so I think we're gonna have time for
some questions I wanna thank everyone
for their attention my bulldog gift
won't work cuz I pulled up the wrong one
he usually Falls to sleep at this point
but I'll fix it in the slides that go on
the youtubes and we do have some
references and we'll update this as well
so let me stop there and Jake to come up
and we'll see if we've got some
questions and we finished as we thought
right on time okay Jay's gonna Mike's
the chicken stand okay yes in the back
that's okay yes
I think that around the country places
are beginning to realize that we need to
start earlier I'm doing projects right
now in Pennsylvania and Long Island
working with high schools high school
staff parents and students and working
with them to build a lot of the skills
that Fred and I have talked about this
morning and simultaneously working with
some of the area colleges and community
colleges so I think but it's taken and
well let's put it this way I'm standing
here in Connecticut but I have to work
in other states in order to so I think
it's taken probably a good 10 or 15
years to start getting this across to
people I think we had to have the
pendulum go this way that parents have
had to advocate so strongly in order to
get students what they have needed in
order to get a good solid education and
move on to to college I think now the
pendulum is swinging in a different way
not back necessarily but now I really
try and emphasize with parents what to
advocate for because sometimes I have to
say to parents you're asking for more
accommodation then my son who's very low
functioning on the autism spectrum and
not going to college you're asking for
more accommodation then he would be
getting in a setting and if you're
expecting that how can that student go
on to college I talked to a family
yesterday they're their student has a
one-to-one aide all the way through
senior year and when I said well how
will that how will that your student
function without an aide and they said
oh no no the college will provide an
aide for and I said no that's never
going to happen first of all if your
student were a quadriplegic in a
motorized wheelchair the college
couldn't provide an ad that's against
federal law personal
service that has to come from a
different agency there's no way for
behavior and attention the college is
going to so I think parents need to hear
this earlier so that they can assist in
some of these independent living pieces
and I think families need the support
there isn't a lot of support out there
for the families and so a lot of what I
keep doing in my work with high schools
is saying yes we need to maybe change
what what we're providing to the student
but we need to support the family
through this or it's not going to work
and that's where a lot of the disconnect
is I could just add to that it's
interesting when you think about it one
of the problems I've got some resources
up here we don't have a tremendous
amount of good solid scientific data we
have a lot of chapters of books which is
great we know a lot already there's not
this is not an area where there's a lot
of peer-reviewed scientific papers
there's a handful of 20 papers on autism
and vocational supports there's a
handful like I think - about suicide in
adolescents and adults in the autism
spectrum
I know it's a problem but there's
literally two papers one of which is a
review of the other paper so it's that
kind of thing is a problem on the other
hand there's some very interesting data
that make us feel like we're if we knew
more we'd have a better sense of what
the problem area is there's a paper from
soup white or college I think it's
University of Virginia Tech actually I
think anyway so soup white they look at
700 students in the college just
randomly students out of every kids
roughly and they give them two measures
of autism diagnosis ones a quick and
dirty autism screener ones a little
longer the SRS is dimensional screeners
I recall between one and two percent of
this big group of kids qualified under
one or two of these as the only autism
spectrum in terms of difficulties they
were unidentified so the question is how
do they how do they get this forum one
without being unidentified also we do
have come across occasional cases with a
person in college very high-functioning
people is gone
well all of a sudden maid services and
he realized what's going on the person
has has had some social skills and
really pretty well all things considered
but if college sort of level kicks up so
much that that's when they need support
and I can't it's a very interesting area
we need to know also about the students
gotten through without supports and
again it's a whole other very
interesting package I have one person I
worked with who was in law school and
wanted to be a public defender and this
was a mistake and the reason was his
client would say to him well I did the
crime and then he would say well we have
to plead guilty and he didn't get the
point no no that's not you're done your
job is to advocate for him to get him
off and so I helped him get into patent
law which is much better fit for him
being a public defender which was a
disaster which that kind of thing and
also if you're working individually with
kids as you know I do in a limited basis
over the long haul and he gets build
them small interventions can make a big
difference I have one student is now at
a school in Boston that'll be nameless
but technology Oregon it and he came in
with a state complain anyone to have a
girlfriend we went through a whole thing
with him one of the things towards the
end of the time I was working with him
he was going up in a double date and he
came in and he looked at me which was
unusual
he really did look at me I said dr. volp
my my friend I'm going on the statement
he says he's gonna take me to Macy's and
because I look like a geek and dr. what
where do I look like the geek I said yes
you look like a geek well what can I do
about it so we got in this whole
discussion and this is a kid who came in
every time his top button buttoned no
time and I said and you know what we're
gonna do something and if your mom is
mad at me I'll pay for the shirt but
we're gonna take off that top button
with the scissors oh I couldn't do that
I couldn't to face my clothing I said
I'm willing to bet you money if we do
that a your mom won't mind and B you
will come in next week was ten dollars
to give me because I've won the bet the
people will tell you a core and of
course I did get ten dollars but it's
that kind of thing that sometimes
immediate feedback
the student learn find out what other
kids are listening to in terms of their
music yes it's not vogner but it's okay
that's what they're listening to that's
what you can then talk about right so
it's that kind of stuff if you're
willing to work with the student could
make a big difference in terms of
setting up so tell us what the best
schools are tell us some of the better
schools okay and not sing good at the
moment I guess good program good
colleges that have programs for students
on the spectrum that's that's what you
mean and again and I want to caution
with saying this it so depends on the
student and the fit but I'll also say
Fred and I do this and do college
counseling with families and we're doing
an increased amount of it and I'm doing
more than I would ever imagine there are
some programs that have more intensive
assistance for students that offer more
hours per week I think there's two that
come to mind at the Marshall University
in West Virginia has had the first
program in the country for college
students on the spectrum and they have a
it's through their Autism Center there
Kelly Autism Center which is right on
campus and it's a wonderful program and
they offer a lot for students on the
spectrum
Mercyhurst College in Erie Pennsylvania
offers wonderful services and one of is
one of the only two programs in the
country that has a residential a
supported residential situation they
have a graduate student who lives in
what used to be their graduate student
residence hall that now is just for
students on the spectrum in their
program that that they run and the
students that we all said oh is anybody
really going to want to live with other
students on the spectrum the students
who are there love it and they're
actually oversubscribed and they're
thinking of opening a second a second
residence hall because the students
really like being in a place with other
people who share their interests and
share their the movies they want to
watch and if they want to watch Disney
movies they're comfortable doing that
and bless you I think it's a wonderful
opportunity if that's what people need
universe
if Connecticut has a very good support
program I helped start the program but I
work 40 miles away at the law school but
they have a very good program a lot of
the colleges in Pennsylvania that we're
working with have really great programs
and they're going to spread throughout
the state there are only one or two in
Pennsylvania I'm sorry in California UC
Irvine is really the only State
University in California which is
surprising Santa Fe College in Florida
it's actually the a community large
Community College of 25,000 students and
they're starting a program they already
have a number of students on the
spectrum and they're starting a program
that deals with employment so they're
doing internships with students which we
are big proponents of because that's
really what students need is lots of
rehearsal in their employment setting
while they're getting that college
degree
that's a few there's more on the list on
the website College autism spectrum and
the new programs that are starting all
the time there are an increasing number
there tend to be pockets around the
country which families really want
someplace near home and often they're
not close to home
secrecy some of the students in college
I've seen have been most successful have
been students when high school basically
were forced to go out and do something
in the community one person I know who
was actually coming to Yale his mom made
him go to Kohl's and take a sales course
so he had to be working at Kohl's he had
to learn how to sell stuff and he he
talked about how that was very helpful
to him it was structure to get his tasks
he responded to questions he could tell
people her stuff was I was scared for
the price but again it's teachable stuff
and he learned it in a setting where he
was really were quite he had some
support he learned on his own and it's
been very successful for him often it's
those employment skills that even and
employers are telling us when we're
saying where where is the where is the
block for students on the spectrum
they're saying I will take a student
with a work history who knows how to be
an employee over a student who has a 3.9
or 4.0 GPA any day I
want someone that I know knows how to
get to work on time knows how to work
with other people knows how to dress for
work and address other people over the
person who might be the brightest person
in the room so what we really are trying
to address with students is you may
still be the brightest person in the
room but let's get you those other
skills so that we can put the whole
package together and not have you just
be the brightest person who's ever
graduated from your program but an
employed person getting and keeping jobs
is the goal that were that we're looking
for getting people through college we've
been working on for a while now we want
to work on those two transitions the
transition into college and the
transition out of college into
independent adulthood
other questions
would you have any advice for friends of
students inspector
learn
I think so increasingly colleges even
colleges without structured programs for
students with autism are providing peer
mentors especially social mentors and I
think the more inclusive we can be the
term most a lot of college folks are
using now is neuro diversity one college
is even running a neuro diversity
initiative rather than an autism program
because they want to take the autism
word out I think more accepting you can
be a lot of people even though we don't
realize it socially we feel
uncomfortable if people dress very
differently we feel uncomfortable if
people talk different or look different
and I think as friends if we can maybe
be more sensitive to people's sensory
issues as Fred mentioned dining halls
are so difficult for students or busy
bars or busy eateries or cafes that all
that sensory stuff going on maybe
meeting with a friend that you know has
some autistic tendencies or is
neuro-diverse meeting with them in a
quieter place doing something more quiet
maybe not with a large group of people
but maybe just two or three I think that
can help a lot that's a very good
question we follow up with a little stop
because we're almost out of time I went
Wallingford a year or two ago and talked
to the Boy Scouts the reason was the Boy
Scouts had hit a kid who come in and
they had Asperger's and I'm changing us
a little bit to protect the child's
confidentiality but anyway he can only
talk about toasties that's all I wanted
to talk about was his toaster collection
he had a lot of toasters and we got no
whole discussion about the a words
autism and Asperger's and I realized
part of the hang-up for the kids was
they didn't understand what that was and
it's also scary and I said okay let's
talk about this not as autism Asperger's
let's talk about this as a problem of
learning it's a social learning
disability then we had a whole
disability
discussion to people no folks with
glasses hearing aids canes
that's a vert that's a visual verbal
obvious disability other kinds of
disabilities are hidden spelling
disabilities how many people don't smoke
no wearing fall so then we got into this
whole thing and then we could have it
talked about strategies when the kid
comes up to you and wants to talk about
his toasters what do you say I would
like to talk about something else that
I'm interested to you or I would like to
hear from you something you're
interested in apart from the toasters
were coming but again to give in a
positive supportive way good feedback
officially want to make a connection and
at the same time modeling how you do
that and I think approaching it through
the kind of disability or you know route
and the whole business about
neurodiversity is probably much more
fruitful than getting into all the
awards I think that's true I I love the
question because I think increasingly as
I often tell people a little bit younger
than myself there were a lot younger
this is really a societal issue this is
going to be your next-door neighbor's
the person running your dry cleaning the
people that are your your kids parents
autism is just this going to be a part
of our life many of the same things will
be helpful students on the spectrum will
be helpful to other college to this well
the things I've been pushing for it so
far unsuccessfully we have a great
people here know about anxiety
management and strategies for anxiety
management you could do a workshop in a
college you know stress management test
anxiety and it's applicable to everybody
not just the students with learning
problems everybody has trouble with
anxiety and so it's the kind of thing
that you can sort of build it with more
generic support that will be helpful to
the whole community
I agree thank you very much thank you
thank you